what I did is I made it a so proper I
was like what if people kiss while
zombies are trying to eat them and then
people were like I like this romance
stuff is a relation I mentioned in that
guy stuff I mean I'm a huge fan of
zombie lore and zombie stories and there
had never been you know the zombie movie
that never ends it was what I've always
said Walking Dead is there never been a
story that that focused on the
characters and showed how they lived
from year to year to year after the fall
of civilization
you know most Sami stories are about the
initial outbreak and things happen and
they trying to survive and they live in
a place for a while and then they all
die or they all right up into the sunset
you never see them again and to me you
know not only like like seeing people
trying to find food and trying to build
shelter and trying to protect their
families that stuff's very fascinating
but also like living in these extreme
situations and just changing
fundamentally how we interact with each
other and how we relate to each other
and you know because in The Walking Dead
it becomes very scary very quickly to
encounter a new person let alone a
zombie you know because you have no idea
what other people have done to survive
and how their mindset has changed
because of this and whether they want to
rob you or kill you or whatever is
happening and so seeing people you know
struggle through this world you know it
was you know fascinating to me and as a
writer when I'm like oh oh next I think
well hopefully there'll be some readers
out there viewers out there that also
want to see it we'll see what happens
next
yeah so what it does is you are living
in extreme conditions when the zombies
are coming and it's not just one thing
it's not just the flood or a crash these
things are out there and they want your
brains so what does your study of
anthropology tell you about how we
civilized people behave under those
conditions my people say that maybe
human beings aren't as inclined to sort
of kill one another under conditions of
scarcity as we think they are
really that's very hopeful yeah it's
hopeful yeah I don't believe any of it
but it's hopeful